there's no time o clock why hey
everybody its episode 168 we're still
worn out from the Halloween show yeah oh
it was almost six hours yeah you know
but a lot of people like you know liked
it and also a lot of people commented
about how cool the background was so we
decided to do this one with this
background to change it
yeah we're just like just a matter of
like moving my laptop around moving some
chairs around [ __ ] like that this is
just yeah it's just a different angle so
you know that's super exciting it's
Jenny's office it is yeah with all my
crap in it yeah
so on this episode we're just going back
to like discussing one case and I had
and I had this guy on my list for like a
long time but I particularly wanted to
do him this week because he died in
prison on October 27th this is Ivan
Milat the perpetrator of Australia's
notorious backpacker murders so we're
gonna get into that a little while yeah
he's actually one of Australia's most
prolific serial killers that he killed
seven that they know of but they think
that there are very likely more of them
and there was also a horror movie that
was loosely based on him so I'll get
into that in a little bit so before we
do that though we'll do our regular
shout outs like we do you know faceless
villain 3 as I say every week you know
out in all formats also my short story
collection associated villanies also out
in all formats as I said my other short
story collection hopeful monsters will
also be up shortly I don't know how long
it's gonna be but because I haven't got
to like recording yeah I did like a
little bit of it but I'm sheathing like
working on it slowly but it might be
it'll probably be it by the end of the
I also had a couple of shout outs for we
have a new patron named Heather so thank
you very much for that thanks Heather
we also got a donation from Marcus and a
donation from friend of the show Melanie
who sends us donations
rather you know a regular basis so it is
all much appreciated so do you want to
just get right into it or do you have
anything that you would like to add your
warm it up yeah cuz we're we're
recording this a little bit early like
in the early afternoon so we decided
like yes I might want to like save the
drinking it so later on we don't want to
like be a drunk before we even go there
so as I said this week we're just
focusing on one [ __ ] this
[ __ ] guy now if you guys saw the 2005
Australian horror film Wolf Creek which
I think they made a sequel and they
might have also made like series of it
later - it's a very the movie was very
disturbing particularly one thing I
remember and like I said it's loosely
based on him but a lot of the [ __ ]
that's a that's you know about the
killer and stuff is kind of similar to
him but one thing that I remember from
this movie which was taken a little bit
from real life was a thing that he would
do like with his knife and he would like
put it in a particular part of their
spine so that they were paralyzed but
they still knew what was going on you
know what I mean and he called it head
on a stick you know what I mean like he
would take these people and just like
paralyzed him so they would just lay
there but they knew what was happening
to them like yeah it's fun doing that
yeah so and that was one thing I
remember from the movie and then when I
found it it was based on a real guy and
then I went back and read and I was like
oh man this dude is like super [ __ ] up
tell us about it yeah so
as I said Ivan Milat was responsible for
they think at least seven murders which
took place needs to do something about
this like I said there's nothing to be
done about it now because that guy just
recently died which is why I moved him
up on the schedule yeah so he's
responsible for at least seven murders
which happened in New South Wales
Australia between the years of 1989 and
1993 although like I said there were
probably some other ones that took place
before that as I said his crimes were
the basis of the 2005 film Wolf Creek
although that guy was also kind of based
on this other guy named Bradley John
Murdoch who was an Australian criminal
and he got life imprisonment for killing
an English backpacker named Peter
Falcone Oh in Australia and that was in
July 2001 so those two guys together
because they both killed like you know
hitch hikers backpackers you know
tourists generally that were just going
around the country and you know
travelling around the country and
staying in hostels and stuff so this
[ __ ]
I'm gonna go back to my other notes over
here and we will kind of start at the
beginning of the story because like I
said for a long time there were
backpackers going missing but no one
knew exactly what had happened to them
you know what I mean until like all
these bodies started turning up and then
they didn't know that it was Ivan Milat
until much later so for a while they
were just called the backpacker murders
because some people were missing for
years and they didn't find them until
later on so 19th of September 1992 there
are these two guys doing orienteering
which I didn't know what the hell that
was so I had to look it up but a pair do
you know what that is okay yeah I don't
know if that's just I don't know if they
use that word in American lingo but
orienteering is it's generally they they
take you it's like a competitive sport
type of thing not necessarily but
usually when they say orienteering they
made it's a competitive thing they put
people out in the woods somewhere
they've never been before and they just
give you like a map and a compass or
whatever you have to like find your way
out you know
we call it land navigation yeah but I
would say looks like they have a thing
where people just like that aren't in
the military where they just do it like
for fun and and it's like yeah it's like
competitive in that yeah I think you get
a map and a compass and they drop you
off somewhere where you never been
before and they have to fit yeah so
orienteering so there's like clubs and
people that do that like for fun so
these two orienteers are out in the
woods on September 19th 1992 and they
smell something really really bad now at
first they think it's a dead animal as
you would but they they kind of go
closer to where this boulder is and they
thought at first they thought it was a
kangaroo because they saw this thing
sticking out and they said it looked
like a kangaroo leg and then they saw
fur but then as they got closer they saw
that the fur was actually the hair on
the back of a human head so the spot
that they were at creepily is called
executioner's drop okay it's just like
this part it's it's called the bole
Anglo national forest it's like a big
national park and stuff and like a lot
of people go hiking through there and
why not and I guess it's called
executioner's drop because it's like a
sheer cliff face or something like that
yeah well not necessarily I think this
was just like the area where it was I
don't think it was at the bottom of the
cliff or anything like that so the
Blanco State Forest is only about 90
miles southwest of Sydney you know so
that's a big city it's only about a
two-hour drive away so they find this
body here and then they call the cops
and the cops start looking around the
same area on the following day
police constable by the name of Suzanne
Roberts found a second body which was
underneath the log and it was only about
a hundred feet away from the first one
now eventually they found out that these
first that these bodies belong to two
British women they were Joanne Walters
who was 22 years old and her friend
Caroline Clarke who was 21 now these
girls like I said they were in
and they had been backpacking through
Australia and had gone missing at some
point in the past and they eventually
ended up finding them in this forest now
these women had both been tied up they
had been stabbed multiple times and I'm
talking multiple you know in the chest
and then turned over seven the back and
[ __ ] like that also shot I believe that
one of them had been sexually assaulted
the other one not it's weird because the
killer had it looked like he had one of
them he had like made her put her shirt
over her face like over her head and
then had her get down on her knees and
then just shot her in the head like an
execution and then once she was down on
the ground and dead he kept like
repositioning her head and shooting it
from different angles like he was just
like having a good time with it or some
[ __ ] like that so this is the kind of
person that we're dealing with if he's
trying to make sure she was really dead
I don't know ten times seems pretty
excessive 22 which is you know pretty
small hole and now yeah you know
possibly a lot of times the bullet holes
pin and what kind of bullet is the size
of it 22 which I'm assuming the police
talking about yeah it actually the wound
closes back up and makes a tiny little
hole and then it stretches the rest of
the ways it goes into the skin then it
goes in then it comes out to the side if
it does come out and a lot of times it
closes back up so a person might think
that it was a tiny puncture yeah so
maybe he thought it what he maybe he was
maybe he was thinking that they were
survivable I don't know they're just
making sure I kind of doubt it like in
in light of his some of his like later
victims that they found an experiment
yeah it just seemed like he was having a
good time with it okay and it seems like
they found like a bunch of cigarette
butts of the same brand like it's almost
like either one of the victims had been
chain-smoking or the killer had been
chain-smoking and that you know implied
that he hung out at the site for like
long time like doing whatever it was
that he was doing to these two girls
nowhere she wasn't afraid of somebody
walking up yes so even from the
beginning they assumed that this was
someone that was familiar with the area
because they knew were like these kind
of remote areas I believe it was
actually they found out later I think it
was actually a right Raul I'm not
entirely sure I'll get to that in a
little bit it's in my notes later on so
when they first found these two bodies
obviously they didn't know who had done
it and they there had been like some
other backpacker disappearances so the
fact that they found these meant that
well maybe we need to like expand the
search like in the same part of the
Belenko National Forest and see if we
can find more bodies so they just called
this person at the time of the
backpacker killer now these first two
victims that had been found they had
actually been missing since May or June
of 1992 now Joanne was originally from
Wales she worked as a nanny caroline was
actually from Northumberland and they
hadn't known each other prior to coming
to Australia but I guess they had met
there like what they were both you know
had come over like you know on a tourist
visa and they had come over and they
were backpacking and hiking and stuff
like that
so they actually were hitchhiking around
the continent which even back then like
even a lot of travel guides even in the
1990s
you know 80s and 90s would tell you that
Oh Australia is very safe country and
it's like you know hitchhiking is kind
of a cheap way to get around and [ __ ]
like that which I guess it was you know
it's you know obviously some people got
murdered but it wasn't like you know it
wasn't like a huge thing where you know
it was kind of like in the United States
like we may be back in the 50s and [ __ ]
like that where 50s and 60s where you
could hitchhike and a lot of people
hitchhiked and it was kind of considered
a safe thing to do like people didn't
really think of it as that big a deal
yeah even though there were there were
like murders that started to happen like
later on but I think a lot of it was
naivete though possibly and get around
what was happening to certain
hitchhikers but over the time people
realized that hitchhiking was a bad idea
yeah true I mean
mayor put yourself at the mercy of
somebody who's picking ya or vice versa
yeah pick up somebody who you know who's
a crazy person yeah could I mean the
hitchhiker might be a crazy person too
you don't know it's like not just how
it's not just the drivers oh yeah
America safe
kinda that's it depends not it depends
on where you are and if you know what
you're doing
it depends yeah but I guess everywhere
does it's like you know no matter where
you are you're gonna get unlucky or not
you know what I mean that's like you
know from the point of view of somebody
maybe grew up in Japan America would be
a dangerous country you know but from
the point of view somebody grew up in
the United States Brazil would be a
dangerous country yeah everything's
relative true yeah but you know like I
said at the time Australia was
considered very safe and it was
considered very friendly and like you
know hitchhiking was kind of a thing so
it's like a lot of people did it and I
guess a lot of people didn't really
think much about it and a lot of
foreigners would come there you know
like from Europe and [ __ ] like then
Japan and [ __ ] like that and would not
really think much of hitchhiking around
although usually they did like take some
safety but like they would always do it
in pairs and [ __ ] like that like no a
lot of people wouldn't hitchhike by
themselves but you know they thought
buddy system I guess was like kind of
their only concession to safety so these
two young women had been like I said
they both been traveling around
separately but they kind of you know met
at a hostel or something and befriended
each other so then they decided to rent
a flat together in Kings Cross the Kings
Cross district of Sydney which was kind
of where a lot of backpackers hung out
and then they decided they were gonna
hitchhike to the south like to do some
fruit picking I guess like to earn some
extra money and they were actually last
seen on the Saturday before April of
1992 which was at the 18th of April yeah
the day before Easter and they were
heading toward the Kings Cross station
carrying sleeping bags and a tent and as
I said that was the last time they were
seen alive and their parents started to
worry about two weeks later because you
know usually they would have called home
once a week or you know they were
missing you know people's birthdays and
holidays and stuff like that so they
actually reported it to the
in there in England and Wales and then
they kind of like coordinated with the
Australians now prior to the two girls
bodies being found in late 1993
obviously their parents were very upset
and we're like both families like travel
to Australia to kind of aid in the
investigation of looking for them you
know they were trying to hold out hope
obviously they didn't want their
daughters to have been murdered so they
were just kind of hoping that they had
you know gone off and hung out with
Aborigines or done something where they
couldn't like contact their family
somehow or something like that now there
was a lot of publicity surrounding this
case so the cops started to look more
into their disappearances and Auster's
also started to kind of link their
disappearances with some other ones that
had happened earlier in that part of the
country so by the time that September of
1993 rolled around when Joanne and
Caroline's bodies were found there were
that they knew of in a related case five
other backpackers who were known to have
disappeared while hitchhiking along Hume
Highway which is the highway that links
Sydney and Melbourne which is also where
they had been similar to the place where
they had been last seen now the first
ones who had disappeared in the timeline
were actually two 19 year old
Australians and they had been on their
way to like a environmental rally or
something like that at the end of 1989
and then in 1991 there had been three
German backpackers one girl on her own
and a couple they had vanished
separately like at separate times you
know over that year well he's got a
specific target he's going after he does
yeah he likes Europeans people were
travelling backpackers yeah out in the
wilderness yeah well and it's people
that and it's people that he could pick
up and he knows that their family isn't
around because they're not and well like
I said the first victims that they know
of were Australians they were actually I
think they were from Melbourne but all
the other ones three of them were
Germans and the other ones
English so it was people who he thought
people wouldn't really be looking for
them or their family was in another
country so you know what I mean so he
thought I could get away identify them
he was in that area yeah yes yeah so as
all this is kind of going on like I said
they're attempting to kind of link
you know once their bodies were found
they were kind of trying to link with
these other disappearances but they
didn't really you know they made an
effort but they didn't set up like a
special task force or anything like that
and like kind of a year went on and they
didn't really find anything else of any
significance however something very
interesting happened once the bodies had
been found the story of their of their
bodies being found was reported in the
British newspapers obviously because the
both of the girls were British now in
Birmingham England there was a guy named
Paul onions he was a air-conditioning
engineer and he had been backpacking
around Australia in 1990 as it happened
and he started reading about this and he
it dredged up a memory of something very
scary that had happened to him at the
time that he had reported but they
hadn't really done anything about and he
had since gone back home like I said
this had been like three years earlier
so it turned out that in January 1990
Paul onions had been hitchhiking around
Australia and he had been picked up by
this guy and he said later on that he
considered he was like the first real
Australian they said he was very he was
a big burly dude he had like a big
zapato type mustache he's looking at the
Hat he had like you know he was a real
like Aussie kind of like Crocodile
Dundee type of character you know what I
mean so you know it would calm a redneck
yeah and like I said they're very very
hillbilly type thing as we will discover
but soon he gets picked up and he said
the guy seemed very friendly he seemed
very normal so he gets in this guy's
four-wheel-drive vehicle to get a lift
but then he says he's in the car for a
little while and once they get close to
the turnoff to the Bell Anglo state
forest
the man's attitude suddenly changed like
prior to that he had been totally fine
totally normal friendly talking just
like regular but they said he got really
really quiet and then he started getting
really like irritable and then suddenly
he pulls a gun out and says he's going
to rob him
now what ended up happening in this case
was that Paul Onion's later reported he
said I saw the gun and that was scary
but he's like that I looked like in
another part of the car because I think
what the guy said was like oh I'm gonna
stop the car or I'm gonna go get some
cassette tapes and then Paul Onion's
looks down he's like there's a bunch of
cassette tapes right there in the
console like in the front seat so what
the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
and then when he kind of glanced back
like that he saw like a bunch of rope so
when the guy pulls the gun out he said
the gun was scary but the rope was
scarier so like the guys it's like I'm
gonna rob you and [ __ ] like that and the
guy very intelligently is like [ __ ] this
and get runs the [ __ ] out at the car
like the guys trying to like restrain
him and he just like runs the [ __ ] out
of the car now the guy actually did
shoot at him but the guy started weaving
like Paul starts weaving back and forth
like holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] and then like
he so he was they were still on a road
so he like runs to the road and he's
like trying to flag down another car and
people like no thank you I don't want to
get involved so then suddenly he said
he's like well okay well the next car
that comes by I'm just gonna jump in
front of it if they hit me they hit me
it's like I don't want to get shot
though so you know so he so this other
car comes by like a van and he just
jumps in it and it's this woman and her
kids and she's like they're like get out
he's like no seriously there's a guy
with a gun just please go so he ran so
that guy got away now he did report it
the same day that it happened right but
it turned out that the cops didn't
really do anything about it at the time
cuz I'm guessing if they even send
anybody out to the area that you know
the guy was long gone by then they also
they made a report but they lost it
somehow don't know fell behind a file
cabinet who knows maybe they did but
this guy said he was like [ __ ] you
know the guy was like [ __ ] shooting
at him while he was running away you
know what I mean it's probably kind of
situation where they those local cops
knew
area and there had never been any
reports of any robberies or anything
happening in that area and they thought
it was one of their local boys taking a
piss out of a yeah out of a tourist yeah
[ __ ] with him which is scary of true
because like I said that's what but it
turned out even though it took [ __ ]
forever for the cops to do anything
about it it turned out that this guy
like actually had a very significant
hand and this guy getting caught later
on so yes so Paul onions like I said he
had made a report but they hadn't really
done anything about it or followed up on
it he subsequently went back to England
and got on with his life like you do and
so that whole thing kind of went nowhere
now not too long after Joanne and
Caroline's bodies had been found on
October 5th 1993 there was this guy
named Bruce Pryor and he was he hung out
in the Blanco State Forest all the time
he like kind of lived near there and he
went out looking for firewood and [ __ ]
like that
so he parks his Jeep in the forest and
he's going around looking for firewood
like he usually does however on this
particular day he found a human thigh
bone now first like I said he thought it
was a kangaroo but then he picked it up
and saw the end of it he's like no
that's totally human and then he's
looking around as he's part of a skull
so obviously he calls the cops
now when the cops came and recovered
these remains they were determined to be
to belong to 19 year old Deborah Everest
and she had last been seen on December
30th 1989 and it was her and her friend
James Gibson they had been the ones that
had been hitchhiking to an environmental
rally so they had been at a backpackers
hostel in Sydney and that was the last
time that they had been seen alive they
had told other people there that that's
where they were going they were going to
this particular festival and they were
gonna hitchhike there and that was the
last time they were seen as I said it
was along the Hume Highway which is
pretty much where all the victims
disappeared from now her body was too
decomposed like I said she was mostly
just the skeleton and I don't believe
they recovered the full skeleton so they
couldn't really tell what exactly the
cause of death was although it did
appear that
had been hit with a sharp object
probably stabbed in the head and in
various other parts of the body they
found her bra and either pants or
underwear that had been cut off so they
found those at the site also it appeared
that she had also been gagged
with her own tights now when they looked
around when they kind of like expanded
the area of the search they also found
the body of her friend James he was
about a hundred and sixty feet away from
hers he had been it seemed like that you
know the killer who I'm gonna say it's
it's Ivan Milat they know who it is now
but they had he had kind of like covered
him up with branches and [ __ ] like that
but didn't make that much of an attempt
to hide them you know and I mean just
kind of threw some sticks and leaves and
[ __ ] over him so this this other victim
James had multiple stab wounds to the
lungs heart and liver and had that blow
to the spine which they believe would
have paralyzed him they think what
happened at this stage you know in in
this particular scene was that the
killer stuck the knife into the guy's
spine which paralyzed him and then they
think that he made the guy like watch
paralyzed while he did [ __ ] to the girl
and then he killed the guy you know what
I mean yeah so they think that's what
happened there so they think too that he
might have either immediately tied up
people there and there's also
speculation too that there might have
been more than one killer I'll get into
that a little bit later too because none
of the bodies had any defensive wounds
meaning that the guy either knocked them
unconscious or tied them up immediately
or had more than one person you know
restraining them or paralyze them before
they could do anything you know what I
mean none of the bodies had any
defensive no one live to tell it to
other no other than Paul Onion's like I
said the guy that ran the [ __ ] out of
the car when the guy pulled a gun on him
he was the only one they know if it like
survived mmm that survived it could be
that he got the jump on him quick he
knew how to manipulate him and control
things yeah and then he tied him up
that's kind of what I'm thinking using
some kind of ruse I'm gonna Rob you I
think that's what he had it well they
they're speculating that that's probably
what happened because like I said Paul
onion said that was what the dude did
it's like he just pulled a gun stuck it
in his face and said I'm gonna Rob you
yeah that's probably what he was doing
yeah probably and reassuring him
everything be all right then once he had
them all tied up
yeah it's like oh I won't hurt you just
give me your stuff so at this point once
these bodies have been found
obviously cops are like well this has to
be a serial killer because you know the
similarity of all the scenes and you
know the proximity where they were all
dumped and stuff like that so on October
12th 1993 they actually finally formed a
special task force called task force err
it was supposed to be err like II yre
which is like a forest near there
because they like to give him like
geographical names but because of the
pronunciation everybody now just bells
at a IR because that's like everybody's
like why is it called task force err
that's why I wasn't supposed to be air
like the air that you breathe it was
supposed to be air like a like a
geographical place near there so they
formed a special task force now they
initially had 20 detectives assigned to
the team you know along with other of
like forensic experts and stuff like
that so three days later they bring in a
bunch of like sniffer dogs and stuff and
they added a bunch of extra police
officers and they're trying to like
search this area like they're doing grid
searches pretty much because they feel
like if they found this many bodies
there has to be some more bodies out
there somewhere because this is clearly
a serial killers dumping ground now um
not too long after that the search
yielded fruit November 1st they found
these skeletal remains of 20 year old
German hitchhiker Simone Schmidt 'el
they found her three miles to the east
of where the other bodies where she had
been 20 years old she had also had
multiple stab wounds she was last seen
on January 20th 1991 she had actually
been in Sydney and her mom was her mom
was in Germany but her mom was coming to
Melbourne like
to visit her coming to Melbourne for
some other reason so Simone was going to
hike like hitchhike down to Melbourne to
visit her mom and she never made it
there so at this point as I said since
they found another body so they just
keep like searching and then they
covered like there's all these fire
trails and [ __ ] like that so they're go
but they're looking through all of those
and they found two more bodies these
were a young couple they were also
German Anya hob she'd she was 20 years
old and her boyfriend Gabor neugebauer
he was 21
now they had also last been seen at a
hostel in the Kings Cross area of Sydney
and they had been going to hitchhike to
Adelaide they had last been seen on
December 26th 1991 so same thing
happened to these they had been tied up
stabbed multiple times you know it's
just they were very very violent
killings Gabor was actually found with a
gag wedged between his teeth he had been
shot six times in the head and also
strangled Anja his girlfriend had been
decapitated with either a sword or a
machete while she was still alive her
head has never been found
now when the forensic pathologist looked
at the bodies he said what it looked
like was that the killer made her like
kneel down with her head bowed and just
chopped her half like an execution like
you know it means like a ritualistic ask
yeah like [ __ ] like that so like I said
this is the type of thing that you're
dealing with now this is as far as I
know this was the first inkling where
dr. Brad Hirsch was the name of the
forensic pathologist who ID'd all the
bodies and it was his opinion that there
was more than one killer and this is
still well this is still a point of
contention to this day because some
people that you know and I'll get into
this a little bit later because Ivan
Milat had the whole family was kind of
[ __ ] up so some people think that
maybe some of his brothers were there
because his brother
also had similar you know criminal
backgrounds and [ __ ] like that but some
people have said because some of the
victims were raped some not some were
shot some were stabbed you know one was
beheaded there was just like a couple of
different demos and it a couple of the
crime scenes there were a couple of
different firearms so they think it
might have been him and one of his
brothers or something like that but like
I said that's none of his other brothers
has ever been convicted of it only he
was but there there is still speculation
that he didn't act alone there's a
possibility but still one man could do
all of these yeah yeah yeah we've
already talked about cases where one guy
got this type of crime done yeah
multiple times you just use a leverage
you pull a gun on a couple actually it
might be easier to take control of a
couple than it would be a single person
because with a couple you have the guy
and the girl there you can actually
leverage the guy to keep the Galman
right to under control that kind of
stuff you know I mean you know just do
what I say and you'll be alright so he's
trying to defend the girl so no one
turns in attacks because one victim is
always concerned about the about the
well-being of the others like you said
that probably is a better and probably
easier yeah because if you do if you do
it with a lone person there's a chance
that that they'll just fight back
against you because they don't have
anything to lose it's all on them
yeah and that they're not responsible
for the death of somebody else that's
actually a good way of putting it and
that might be why I mean this guy that
they know of he did attack simone
schmidt all who was apparently traveling
traveling alone but all the other ones
he attacked but there was two of them it
was either two girls or a girl in a guy
it's been proven over and over again
through all the law enforcement and
military histories and cases going back
this goes back to like the the israeli
defense force that if you have a mixed
group of men and women the men will
instinctively try to protect the women
yeah one of the reasons why i'm not a
real big believer of mixed gender
infancy
yeah I mean everyone everybody in that
entry unit has to be equally expendable
you have to be sit there and be able to
watch other dudes die so other dudes can
live you know I mean I can't yeah the
instincts involved that's one you know
and cases like this kind of show to me a
process of a man trying to defend the
woman yeah so that actually is the
weakness of that group you know he
couldn't fight back because he was
afraid that the woman would be killed
that she would be killed and you know
millat might have known that as well and
it's like I'm sure he probably loved
just like I said yeah if you attack a
couple it's easier to control because it
should be noted that the German couple
Gabor was a big dude he was like six
foot two and he was like kind of a big
muscular like athletic guy he wasn't
just like some skinny you know so he was
a big guy and even his dad later said
that he thought that there had probably
been two killers because he's like look
my son was like a big dude and it's like
it would have taken a lot of people to
kill him but I don't know because he was
like you said he was there with his
girlfriend and he wouldn't have wanted
to see her get killed or get hurt just
go look on there's there's a site on
YouTube called police activities and
police activities body cam footage of
cops dealing with perpetrators and you
will see unarmed perpetrators turning
and fighting against armed policemen
outnumbered sometimes the one they'll
still do it got a lone man is more apt
to just go kamikaze well yeah cuz like I
said that is right and a lot of times
they're saying shoot me go ahead shoot
me yeah and really if I was a woman and
I thought that I was being abducted I
would do that it's much better to just
um I asked them to shoot you I I you
know I've never been in that exact
situation so I couldn't say but I feel
like I would probably rather do that
because look at what could happen if you
allow yourself that's what I mean and
it's like fate worse than death and that
yeah and that's like all this [ __ ] about
like they say like oh I'm not gonna hurt
you so [ __ ] that [ __ ] me
[ __ ] you're gonna have to shoot me I'm
not going anywhere with you that's what
I mean it's like you know it even if
they kill you at least you can [ __ ]
hurt them
yeah but at least try because that's
what I mean because if they take you you
are not coming back many realities
though like you can go back to what
Macduff would do who is another serial
killer he would target women that were
under five feet tall he was a 6-footer
yeah and what he would do is just a
single strike right to the jaw just
knock him out yeah and throw him in the
back of his car
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] you know
yeah there's not really much you can do
and that's it not much you can do I mean
you know I've fought guys that were
bigger than me if am oute if you're
fighting a dude that is big enough to
pick you up off the ground there's not a
whole lot you can do you're gonna lose
yeah yeah no I mean you're gonna have to
like malicious you can there are
physical limitations to human beings
yeah and size is a factor yeah anybody
will tell you this well yeah obviously
I'll tell you obviously if you're just
like some tiny little woman and some big
[ __ ] dude big caveman like they just
just pick you up looks like what the
[ __ ] you can't do anything you don't see
children beaten up adults yeah does
doesn't happen you know yeah and when
you're a six-foot something dude you
know weighing 202 something pounds a 90
pound or 85 pound 4 foot 11 females like
a child compared to him yeah
so you know we just have to be realistic
yeah I mean you can ask any of these MMA
fighters they can tell you the sizes of
Bigfoot it's a big factor yeah so like I
said if you're small you really won you
have to like beast a lot more careful
than maybe you would be otherwise but
also you better be good runner yeah you
better run or you better figure some
other [ __ ] out dude that dude did six
dang you know that guy in IMT individual
movement taggers yeah well I think he
had done some military service and so he
he was like I was somebody shooting me
suits shooting at me so he started
running Zig zaggy to five-second rushes
yeah [ __ ] combat roles but yeah I
think that's why so he knew like
immediately yeah you know his instinct
kicked in he as the notes he was just
like running like that now okay so as I
said so I was talking about the four
pathologist and how like I said there's
there is some like controversy over
whether Ivan Milat acted alone or
whether some of his brothers were there
at the scene or maybe one of his sisters
I'll get into that a little bit later
too
but you know so like I said there's
still no no other charges have been made
he was the only one that was charged
with these so just about just one day
before they found the last two bodies of
the German hitchhikers they first
started talking about Ivan Milat now how
he came to the attention of the police
was that one of the guys that he worked
with
apparently reported him to police just
because he kind of had like he was like
super super into guns he was like this
is gonna be I and kind of was sketchy
and weird and like acted kind of
aggressive and stuff so they reported
him to police it's maybe you know it was
that kind of thing now they also had
like a tip line and you know so a lot of
Australians were like calling in various
tips and stuff so they had to kind of
like wade their way through those and
all this other stuff so now that Ivan
Milat has kind of like appeared on the
police radar let's talk a little bit
about him because like I said he was
convicted of these so he is as you know
as far as our one knows and he died now
but they're talking about he's now the
backpacker murder so he was born in 1944
he was born in Australia his mom was
Australian his dad was Croatian his dad
was actually much much older than his
mom I think he was like twice her age
maybe she was only like 17 or 18 when
they married and he was like twice that
age so they ended up having 14 children
like like he did back then I guess now
Ivan's father whose name was Steven he
had actually been in the British Army in
World War one and when Ivan was a kid he
actually worked as a laborer on a wharf
and he he worked like every day pretty
much so he was like always gone they
didn't really have a lot of education
all these kids you know that it was a
very like working-class and like
I said I watched a bunch of
documentaries about this and even in
Australia they said these are like
hillbillies it's like a hillbilly family
like they kind of lived in this little
three-bedroom house he's 14 kids and
they're yeah this is kind of like this
they apparently they had like bunk beds
but there was like three of them right I
mean they slept in those ya know so
apparently so the dad and you see this a
lot in these kind of serial killer
situations the dad was like super super
strict very very distant and not its
strict in a way that it's like oh go to
bed without dinner but it's like if you
did something bad he would just like
step on you and like beat the [ __ ] out
of you you know what I mean it's like so
violent abusive the mom was almost kind
of like the opposite she was um that all
the kids kind of described her she was
kind of like um you know they would just
come to her when the dad and beat not
bought him stuff she was very indulgent
you know she was very nice to them and
probably not good but she whatever they
did it was like they were her perfect
little angels I guess it was like that
type of situation so it's like they
could do no wrong 14:10 boys and four
girls clown car vagina holy crap this
yeah pretty much that's what this is
it's terrible but yeah they're being
fruitful and multiply big-time [ __ ] my
mom's family was like that well like I
said and I think I mentioned this before
too it's like my maternal grandparents
had eight kids
which is you know it's different than 14
but still I mean my mom's family had
nine yeah yeah that's I can't imagine
another era okay how did how did
everybody like keep trying like remember
their names how could you keep track of
where they all were at one time purity
Church you would have to I mean think
about it I was like look I have a hard
I'm keeping track of two cats okay much
less 14 children
they kept Maul under well what are you
gonna do lock them in one room holy [ __ ]
they all left home by the time they were
15 or 16 okay well that was just a
different steer though I'm not even
talking about teenagers I mean once
they're teenagers right get a car get a
job get out of here but it's like what
with their little kids how do you keep
it's like oh this one's ever here like
sticking something in the [ __ ]
electrical socket and that one's over
there trying to climb on top of the
frigerator and that one's doing you know
what I mean it's like my mom used to run
a daycare I know how the [ __ ] goes and
she only had like you know maybe four or
five kids at a time and even that was a
nightmare when my aunt Lois hit like 17
you know back in California in those
days 17 you could leave well yeah II
left home and took my mom with us she's
like let's get out of here
let's get out of here you know like it
was a maximum-security Church yeah
basically I probably would have left it
yes and from what I've heard so they got
an apartment yeah yeah yeah but that's
just way you know they all kind of did
that back in the end this is al it was a
long time ago and single women could
just move out and get apartments and
they made them they made good money keep
the end does this concept these younger
people think that women didn't work
women [ __ ] worked all week but like I
said working-class and middle-class
women always worked yeah they always
work had to and they made money you know
what else he gonna do when I got out of
high school before I joined the Army I
had my own apartment my own car and you
know and I was just a waiter at Denny's
and I made a lot of money for you know
by today's standards yeah I don't think
a waiter at Denny's a 17 or 18 year old
waiter at Denny's it depends where the
where the Denny's is you okay
I think location wouldn't depend a lot
on I was in Trenton Michigan right
outside Detroit I mean you know what I
mean it's just gonna depend on apartment
what neighborhood it's in what state
it's in what's you know that's gonna
it's gonna depend on a lot of things cuz
I invited you probably do it in New York
I know so well yeah well I know some
servers that make a lot of money but I
know
some servers that don't make [ __ ] money
but it depends on where the restaurants
at but what I was wondering about before
is like especially back in the old days
when women had all these kids okay for
one thing it's like nowadays I feel like
there's more of like a co-parenting vibe
where it's like you know dads are more
involved in their kids lives which they
didn't really used to be to the same
extent like back then so you have a
woman with 14 children she doesn't
really have any help from the dad
because he's either always off at work
or whatever the [ __ ] is he's doing so
it's like she has to keep track of all
of these kids like by herself and like
back then I mean this wasn't that long
ago but I mean back in the old days when
we talk about like the 40s 50s [ __ ] like
that it's like think about how much
longer everything took how much longer
cooking tuck how much longer laundry
secondly it's like how the [ __ ] today
how when did they sleep I don't
understand it now they got anything done
well we were growing up in the in the
you know in the seventies in the
eighties you know we were feral that's
true we could just leave yeah we just
ran into that because I mean yeah I mean
even when I yes before dark any a person
yeah I mean even when I was a kid it's
just like just go outside Jesus Christ
get out of my face
that wasn't until like the 80s the part
of the eighties where you had Geraldo
Rivera scaring the [ __ ] out of everybody
that all the children they go they're
all gonna get kidnapped an occult yeah
that was and that was the beginning of
this new millennial type generation stay
in home just playing video games and
helicopter parents and [ __ ] you know I
mean that caused all that but you know
art during our time you know get the
[ __ ] out of here yeah I'll be back
before dark
although bad [ __ ] did it open turns
anything down okay I won't burn nothing
up up that's like I can't promise that
[Laughter]
yeah you and Evel Knievel me and every
other boy on the damn block Jimmy and
Mike and [ __ ] we were all equally Evel
Knievel
it was like the evil Knievel brothers
but keeps jumping off of roofs and so it
was just a bit yeah I remember my
brother hope there's no spring sticking
out there jumped off the back of the dam
yeah jumped off the back of the house
with album jacket do you remember what
records they were there my mom sews
Probert
[Laughter]
well yeah you're like well [ __ ] that
doesn't work like I saw in Marion
seconds I felt that resistance
yeah it's working it's the shades not
working god damn it the movies lied to
me oh my god
so when Ivan Milat was still a fairly
little kid he was about four years old
his dad Stephen who prior to this was
like a laborer on a wharf as I said he
decided that they were gonna be farmers
so he basically recruits all of the
children to work on this new little farm
that they have established I guess it
was mostly just growing tomatoes and
[ __ ] like that so he so he has these
kids like out in the middle of the night
like watering tomatoes it's like none of
them really I guess they went to school
but maybe kind of intermittently because
they were so busy working on a farm but
despite that I mean obviously they
didn't really making a lot of money
especially considering that they had 14
children to feed that's yeah that's what
I'm saying now even though the mom whose
name was Margaret she was like oh it
wasn't hard we all worked hard and you
know and as I said she kind of had a
thing where the kids couldn't do any
wrong it's like oh we never had any
trouble with any of the kids or anything
like that because
no she just didn't know all the [ __ ]
that they were up to or maybe he was
just someone bad seed no they were kind
of all a lot of them were Betsy it's a
lot of them were another thing they were
all like avid hunters they all started
getting guns and things as presents when
they were very very small like four or
five years old you know so they always
had that around the house you know they
would have and they would all go in the
backyard sheet bottles and animals and
[ __ ] like that
not unusual from where I came well not
unusual there either
at that point in time like particularly
in that kind of like working-class area
yeah now yeah except for this guy yeah
well except for kind of most a lot of
this family like I said teaching some
responsibility or if you're already have
a pre-election 44.4 a sociopath a then
yeah they might be some genetic problems
in the house it might be just maybe just
low IQ yeah lack of what do you call it
opportunities well in the case of Ivan
Milat I definitely think that he just
had he seemed to have just no conscience
whatsoever he just seemed one of those
like psychopathic like he just enjoyed
making people suffer people like that
for no reason other than like his own
sadistic pleasure really
yeah he didn't really he definitely did
seem kind of like that like a lizard
so um now Ivan Milat did go to school
like I said and was considered fairly
bright and most of his brothers said
that he was the smartest one out of all
the kids that he was particularly good
artists he was good at math and stuff
like that but as he got a little bit
older he started skipping classes and
during his early teenage years spent a
lot of time in Boys Town which you know
one of those institutions not
necessarily like juvie but kind of for
kids that were like troubled or it came
from like poor backgrounds or what they
would call overburdened families but had
too many kids and they couldn't really
keep track of what
so yeah so that's kind of where he ended
up spending a lot of his time although
you know the none of the teachers at
school or anything like that seemed to
have any problem with him they said he
wasn't a disabled popper or anything
like that at least when he was younger
so at 15 years old I've been leave
school and goes to work as many of his
brothers did he generally ended up
working you know manual labor building
sites and things like that
another thing that a lot of people said
about Ivan was that he was real OCD
about cleanliness and very into like
control and order you know what I mean
like his dad was like that too so I
guess he kind of inherited that where it
seemed like he had to be in control of
all situations he was like everything
had to be super clean and spotless and
particularly the way he wanted it and
[ __ ] like that that makes sense when you
come out of a house that has so many
kids in it they're probably if you don't
keep them in line the place will get
filthy quick so that's probably what
where that's coming from
yeah you that or the place was filthy
and he didn't like it so therefore he
was trying he was trying to rebel
against it yeah I don't see how you have
14 kids I don't see how it could not be
filthy because it's like you you would
literally have to follow every one of
them around like with with a [ __ ]
dust mop and broom like ten boys yeah
ten boys yeah I had two brothers and my
brothers are like not disgusting or
anything like that but even then think
was their boys are dirty that's what I
mean - it's like [ __ ] is there's only
two of us and I do laundry like every
other day and it's usually like two or
three yeah that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying like back then I mean
maybe this was like you know I guess
this was [ __ ] 60s like late 50s early
60s they had washing machines they
didn't have washing machines but so I
don't know if they had one because they
were kind of you know lower
working-class so they might not have so
she this hand washed in it yeah this
poor woman probably had to like hand
wash all of these like dirty disgusting
boys clothes and probably bring them out
on a little wringer
clothes align like it did in the old
fashion I mean you can do it it's not
hard to have people that actually do
though yeah in their apartments I'm
saying York even I'm yeah but it takes
time that's what I'm saying and I'm just
saying and that and the thing is laundry
is not the only thing you have to do you
always have you also have to cook for
them you have to clean up after the like
you have to clean other things you know
up after them that's what I'm saying
it's like I don't understand how people
like that have any time to do anything I
remember you know growing up in the 70s
Mississippi moms working-class moms
their farm girls they were they cooked
and cleaned they used washing machines
though because of course didn't they had
washing machines and electricity no yeah
but it was a but then they'd go out and
do things like pick butter beans yeah
and remember and plant stuff yes they
all had gardens out in the back and you
know it was a good quality life it
wasn't luxurious but you know boy if the
food was bountiful yeah I people to
understand that [ __ ] Southern culture
even poor people that live in rural
areas back in those days all had gardens
getting fresh tomatoes out of their
butter beans corn yeah there was a but
an abundance of food it was like a damn
religion one food you can eat yeah yeah
that's true I think nowadays though I
think probably the the sad thing is that
because the cheapest food like that you
buy the grocery store is usually like
not the most nutritious tasting corn so
so sometimes even though it's not like
you're not starving obviously but you're
probably not getting like all the
nutrition you need
I remember you know like I said it's all
fresh fruit and vegetables watermelons
yes fish you know trout lining lots of
catfish but last time I went back to
Mississippi bet that's all gone down
yeah you don't see it anymore well
that's yeah that's very wrong
yeah I mean well no in the same areas
where they used to do all that it's more
moderate houses now yeah and nobody does
that anymore yeah but it's too
time-consuming the modern world is
encroached
cable-tv changed all that
yeah the advent of cable TV just changed
southern culture forever all that stuff
well because everyone could see how
everyone else's lives and people started
getting you know like aspirational yeah
and all those kids moved away yeah all
those kids mind all the white kids of my
generation from Mississippi don't live
there anymore yeah their parents still
live there but they all moved away yeah
which can't blame them no it's like what
are you gonna do they saw MTV yeah you
know well it's like Iran yeah well and
the thing too it's like if you want to
get like a decent paying job and [ __ ]
like that it's like there's no yeah you
can't really if there's nowhere around
there to do it so like I said you can't
blame them for leaving no I would have
all pretty much they all left ya there
but no yeah if you were worth your [ __ ]
you got the [ __ ] out of that out of
those areas yeah at least went to
Hattiesburg yeah so alright so as I said
Ivan was kind of like a neat freak
they're very his brothers always said oh
he had all his clothes had to be like
immaculate he always had to be like you
know always in control of every
situation um however by the time he was
17 years old he started getting in
trouble for the law usually fairly minor
[ __ ]
breaking and entering usually and
stealin [ __ ] so 1962 he got six months
in a juvenile institution also for
breaking and entering and over the 1960s
he would get four more jail terms for
the same thing
car theft also was another thing that he
did his mom bless her said that oh he
must have just fallen in with a bad
crowd yeah I guess so
so um the cups were you know started
coming around to the house a lot of
times cuz that some of the other
brothers were getting in trouble with
the laws well usually like I said it was
minor [ __ ]
breaking and entering just you know
stealing things from people and the cop
said a very interesting thing even from
this early time in the Millat family was
that the brothers would never rat on
each other
you know I mean so it's a babies like I
don't know I don't know anything about
that so they were always like very
tight-lipped and very like protective of
each other and like I said that kind of
like continued on to the point where one
of them was a serial killer you know I
mean so that's all upsetting
yeah well all but one of them so 1969
the Millat family moves to this suburb
of Sydney called Guildford which was
actually kind of like a little
higher-income little higher rent than
where they had been living and the
mother actually ended up living there
until she died now while they were
living here Ivan's youngest sister
Margaret was actually killed in a car
accident now one of the one of their
brothers Wally had been driving the car
and I guess he hit another car head-on
like accidentally and the little sister
was killed and apparently this really
upset Ivan a lot I was from what I heard
like I guess she died in his arms pretty
much like she just like bled out while
he was holding onto her so that because
the accident was very near the house so
apparently this was like kind of a big
thing in his life that his sister had
died now only about a month after his
sister Margaret was killed he was
charged - this was in 1971 with raping
one of two women that he had picked up
they were hitchhiking near the town of
Liverpool is not Liverpool England this
is an Australian and the the point where
he had picked them up was right around
the same place where most of these you
know the backpacker murders had taken
place like where most of those
hitchhikers hitchhikers got picked up so
they think that this is kind of where
his serial killing serial rapist [ __ ]
began in this 1971 case now he actually
had a hearing for this so he was he was
going to be charged with
and he was also gonna be charged with
two armed robbery charges because one
was like a bank but before he could be
brought to trial he jumped bail and went
to New Zealand and he actually stayed in
New Zealand for like three years like
trying to get away from the cops however
he eventually came back in 1974 and was
arrested again however when he was put
on trial he gets acquitted of the
robbery charges and unfortunately when
he was put on trial for the rape charge
one of the victims that he had picked up
um the girl that had been raped she
either changed her story or she was not
a very good witness
I guess the jury like was not
sympathetic toward her for whatever
reason and he got off with that as well
so so there was that whole thing to
where it seems like he was doing this
kind of [ __ ] from an early age but he
was getting away with it you know what I
mean so later on they found out they
think that millat actually told someone
that um that he had done the bank
robbery and that he had done these
crimes but like someone else got the rap
for like one of his brothers took the
rap for it or whatever so at this point
it seems like he's not like after that
happened after the acquittal it seems
like he's kind of going into like a more
respectable stage of his life you know
let's say so it's 1975 he still lived
with his parents at this point but
because he was such like a control freak
and stuff like that he did not smoke he
did not drink so he was like
straightedge and he wouldn't drink for
that very reason because he said well I
don't want to get out of control so
that's yeah so there was that whole
thing and he was also working as a truck
driver and he works like really long
hours and worked all the time now at
this point he meets the girl who would
become his first wife her name was Karen
and she was at the time only 17 years
old I believe he was in his mid to late
20s at the time now this is something
that Ivan would do a lot
Karin was actually his cousin marks
girlfriend and she was pregnant with his
baby when her and Ivan got together now
later on Ivan would also have affairs
with two of his brothers wives allegedly
at least yeah and interestingly there
were also implications and I've seen
interviews with some of his other
brothers that have said this there were
also implications that Ivan was having a
sexual relationship with his sister
Shirley like they lived together at one
point and one of the brothers I believe
it was Robert or Richard I can't
remember which brother it was there were
so many he actually said that he didn't
think Ivan was the only one that was
banging her either
although he said it wasn't me but he's
like I'm not saying which ones it was
but he's like I think some of the other
brothers were jeez so this is like kind
of a messed up family maybe when you
have so many siblings there they cease
to be siblings they're just people I
think it's kind of like kind of like
kind of like what was his name jingis
calm yeah he had so many relatives that
they might as well not even be relatives
anymore Yeah right yeah well the
fucked-up thing and I was like I said I
saw this interview this this most of his
family like other than the one brother
Boris that actually did come out and say
yeah I think Ivan's a psychopath and
yeah I think he totally did it
but all these brothers they seemed kind
of like creeps and this one in
particular that was saying how he didn't
really he's like well I didn't have you
know I wasn't having sex with surely
their sister but he didn't really seem
to think it was that big a deal because
he said something like oh well look at
those two guys having sex over there is
that any worse than like a guy happens
like banging his sister and I was just
kind of like what like just a hypothetic
he was making it oh I don't like gay
people joke he's like oh it's the same
thing yeah it was pretty much that and
I'm like Oh charming that's really
charming
so yeah this whole [ __ ] family it's
like so I don't know I don't know if
Ivan was banging the sister but a lot of
the other kind of like little brothers
did really seem to think so and I think
so
it's kind of like that British family
where the West's yeah where they just
you know had sex with everybody yeah
yeah the kids the [ __ ] siblings well
it's just sex
yeah it's just sex so yeah I don't know
if it's like true or not when you're a
psychopath I think that's basically kind
of what ends up happening yeah yeah yeah
it's just torture yeah it's like they
really don't seem to have any it's like
they like a robot
yeah they don't really seem to have it
everything is like on the same yeah
don't level dimensional everything's on
the same level it's like this is the
same as this yeah you know well you know
you burn a cat alive you know Hey well
yeah yeah eat chicken yeah that's what I
mean they they would they would think
that those two things were that was a
difference you know you're eating
chicken you're burning cats alive you
know you try to stuff a damn Greyhound
alive into a boiling pot of water well
hey you know you eat cows yeah yeah
that's like exactly how they you know
there's no like moral continue over this
lives there's nothing like that
everything is just like ah same it's all
the same yeah and I kind of get that
vibe and I really got that vibe but this
one particular dude like comparing like
a gay relationship to incest
he doesn't like didn't see a distinction
between those two those Simoes brain
studies almost psychopath said that no
matter all the stimulus you give them of
the reaction it's about to say is about
the same so that's probably their kind
of basically what it is is that they're
they have muted emotional reactions
they're just yeah clearly so when you
when you don't really have emotions and
you just kind of robotic or lizard like
everything probably does yeah a little
not the same yeah everything is just
nothing's any worse than anything else
nothing's any better than anything else
everything is just yeah this flatline
and then but killing somebody it might
be a spike in your emotional yeah output
like you might give it an endorphin rush
off of that yeah it goes back to that
which is probably why they do it because
they can't it's the only thing it's the
only thing that causes a react
action and inner reaction and that would
explain to why it usually like gets
worse and worse as it if they don't get
caught they have to keep yeah and yeah
and I think that's why that just keeps
getting worse and worse until they get
caught usually this doesn't always
happen like so you dealing with a person
that for some reason another just didn't
develop yeah along a normal line you
know I mean they're just emotionally
kind of dead yeah because I think that
was some of the stuff that they reported
is that they're just well how did you
feel about that and they're like well
nothing yeah they didn't feel anything
about anything yeah which is scary right
that's that's very scary actually we're
probably about at the halfway point so
let's take a break right now for a
couple of little commercials little Katy
videos you know like we do in the middle
of the show baby cookies over there with
one of those mint toys I showed you and
she rubs it it's funny the little mitt
so I guess it's like a little you know
it's like a chew toy but it's also it's
like you know narrower in the middle and
then it's got little black big mint
leaves on the end so when she picks it
up in one little paw and like holds it
like that it looks like she's like has a
tiny little dumbbell I was like look she
looks like she's doing tiny little curls
because she's just like oh she put it
down now she's just laying on her back
like she does but a little feet stick it
over there all right so when we come
back we will talk more about Ivan Milat
and the backpacker murders
what's he doing what's he doing yeah
whoa look at this loyalty you are so
funny okay why are you only laying like
that oh my goodness oh goodness oh yeah
[Laughter]
what you doing oh yeah roll oh don't you
do it don't you do it oh good girl
I'm gonna come over here and do it what
you can't see me you know your novel
subscribes on that even that you do all
the time anyway cookie does not give a
[ __ ] not one bit
she doesn't care what we say she just
says what she wants that's okay okay
she's cute so she gets away with you
love true crime I love true crime and
I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry babies case the
Frog Boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back now where was I we
were talking about Ivan Milat and how he
had so he ends up marrying his first
wife Karen who as I said was 17 at the
time they met in the mid-1980s
apparently they had a wedding but most
of the family wasn't invited because it
was something feud going on about
something or another there was also
another because as I said Ivan's sister
Margaret had been killed a car accident
also he had another brother David that
right around the time that he got
married was in a motorcycle accident and
he didn't die but he was permanently
brain-damaged because that was another
thing these these kids like all the boys
particularly were super into you know
cars motorcycles guns all the hunting
all that kind of stuff
so they were all very outdoorsy that
type of person that you know so so they
were always like driving fast like
riding motorcycles faster like that so
you know a couple of them were killed
that way or one was killed that way and
that one got brain damage
so Ivan gets a job for the Department of
Main Roads like I said he was driving a
truck so he was away for several days at
a time he was also kind of a cheapskate
so I guess that was kind of an issue
like with his new wife and as I said she
had been pregnant with his cousin's baby
at the time so I guess the son that was
born was named Jason and so he was
raising the stepson like as his own kid
it was also around this time that he
started having an affair with at least
one of his brothers wives possibly two I
think this was his brother Walter's wife
her name was Maureen and his brother
Boris I think that he also was screwing
that wife as well but I don't know if it
was at the same time or not um also not
surprisingly Ivan Milat was abusive
toward his wife like I said he was also
super OCD about cleanliness so he was
always like if something was out of
place he'd like flip out about it and
everything and you know so he was always
like beating her and whatnot so finally
Valentine's Day of 1987 oh there she
goes again
[Laughter]
cameraman Katie she's being camera candy
yeah what are you talking about she's
like what are you talking about she
wants to go out there so Valentine's Day
of 1987
ivan is away at work and karen has
decided that she has had enough of his
[ __ ]
so she packs up all her stuff in the
house with her mom's help and took off
she took all the furniture she took all
her [ __ ] everything and apparently she
went into I don't know if it was her
letter a later girlfriend but she I
think went into witness protection
particularly after he got caught and
convicted as being a serial killer so
because he didn't see her for another 7
years she just cut off all contact she
just like took off so 1989 Ivan Milat
quit his regular job and started working
kind of under the table because he
didn't want to one he don't want to pay
taxes and two he didn't want Karen to be
able to claim any of his income so like
I said he starts working like on the
down-low so after the divorce was final
that's when he first started picking up
hitchhikers
and killing them so there seemed to be
some kind of pattern where whenever he
would do these Purdy's rapes and murders
because as I said you know the first
time he did it allegedly was 1971 and it
was only a month after his sister was
killed in a car accident
now when Deborah Everest and James
Gibson who were the first ones that he
killed like in the late 80s when when he
killed them it was only a short time
after his divorce was final so they
think that it had something to do like
most of the time it seemed like he was
kind of mostly you know keeping it
together but then like when some
stressful thing happened like he would
go out and like take it out on other
people you know what I mean yeah because
it seems like he wasn't doing it all the
time but it's just like anytime
something like a big traumatic event
like happened in his life
it would kind of trigger I'm gonna do
some kind of say that it was kind of
like a pressure that builds up in them
that they have to blow off steam like
you said yeah and they did it by killing
all the people yeah and you'd some to
get some kind of an endorphin rush I
guess yeah I definitely do think that
there was like that kind of you know
that kind of thing yeah so it does
definitely seem that I mean coming back
up to nineteen ninety-three now when
they had you know discovered all the
bodies of you know the people that this
guy had killed and they were kind of
able to place it all in a timeline and
figure out would have been going on it
did seem like when they were looking
into you know the method of murder all
of them of all of them the first three
victims they thought were killed fairly
quickly even though there had been
sexual assault there had been other
things like that but it did seem like
the first three victims mostly were just
marched into the woods and he's either
raped and then shot but as time went on
it does seem like he was like upping the
ante you know I mean because by the time
it got to like the German couple he was
doing SH it was sort of like beheading
that girl with a sword and you know all
that kind of [ __ ] so it does definitely
seemed like he was ramping up and making
it more horrific like as time went on
yeah and another thing too that they
found out was that and sometimes he
would like move them from the scene like
he would you know he would kill them at
one place then move them somewhere else
or another thing that he would do they
found like a lot of spent shell casings
like at some of the scenes almost like
and like some beer bottles that he had
shot almost like he was showing off like
his marksmanship skills like for the
victims or something like that you know
what I mean it's so it seemed like he
was making it more into like a game you
know what I'm saying because they think
that that he was in this place it was
him and you know whoever else was with
him or if it was just him alone
that he was spending a lot of time in
the woods with these victims doing
various things you know what I'm saying
so and they think that that was ramping
up like as time went on they also think
that the two English girls who were
actually the first ones found but I
think they were either there were some
of the last ones that had disappeared
but they were the first bodies that were
found they he had like made them take
their clothes off and they put their
clothes back on and it's like so he was
doing like all this other kind of [ __ ]
to them you know and and it had got more
like to the point where you know one of
the girls was stabbed like 20 times like
you know like in the front and then made
her turn over like turned her over and
stabbed her a bunch more times in the
back and like I said the whole thing
that he did with the gun like turning
that girl's head
they they think that he turned her head
and then shot again in the turn head
shot again and turned head shot is like
ten times which I don't think that had
anything to do with like making sure she
was dead I think he was just doing that
because he got off on it maybe after
their daddy stays in that area with them
and plays with him yeah that's yeah and
that's what a lot of the experts said
too they said that that he's basically
using them for target practice like even
after they were dead and a lot of times
too he would keep stabbing them after
they were dead like he was having a good
time with it you know what I mean and
like I said not all of them are raped
some of them were but so was it you know
was it sexually motivated probably
partially but not entirely it just
seemed like he just sadistically got off
he I think he got off on controlling the
situation is you know what I mean he had
that kind of he had like a BTK thing
where he had to be in control of
everything
I kind of suspect that there might be
some necrophilia I mean I suspect that
because something like one of the
documentaries that I was watching about
him one of the experts said you know I
was like listening to an interview with
him or he interviewed him or something
like that and he said he's he said
something like that that implied that he
was gonna like kill them and then have
sex with them you know what I mean like
the wording that he used sounded like
there was like he can take his time yeah
nobody's watching them even the victims
are watch them because they're gone yeah
so he can play with yeah it really does
seem like that yeah type of thing you
know he's not being scrutinized or
judged about what he's doing right but
so like I said now when they found the
bodies and like I said when they had
kind of expanded the search and they had
found all these bodies instead
they didn't know that it was Ivan Milat
yet at this point like he had just come
kind of come on the radio braids are in
late 1993 but they weren't entirely sure
who they were looking at they have like
a lot of suspects and stuff all they
knew was that this was a guy he drove a
four-wheel-drive vehicle he probably
lived around that area was familiar with
the Blanco State Forest they did find
like the ballistics experts found out
that they knew that the same gun had
been used to kill Gabor who was one of
the German hitchhikers and Caroline
who's one of the English hitchhikers
with two different scenes this was a
us-made Ruger 10/22 rifle now there were
about fifty thousand of them in
Australia but Australia's a big country
so you know so it wasn't a common gun
but it wasn't super rare either you know
I mean like a lot of people had them but
it wasn't the most common US is like
water yeah but yeah a lot of people had
them but it wasn't the most common one
in Australia in the u.s. is just like
yeah so they were kind of hopeful that
that would like help them like narrow
the shut down you know what I mean they
also knew that the danger period for the
killings was right around holidays right
summers Christmas break Easter break
cause you know tub you know summer is
opposite in Australia because it's in
the southern hemisphere
so that you know it's actually December
and [ __ ] like that because all the
backpackers pretty much disappeared
right around that time so and they also
knew that the killer was probably a
hunter they also knew that the
hitchhikers had probably been killed on
the same day that they had disappeared
because they were always found in the
same clothes that they had last been
seen in another interesting thing was
that even though they found like some of
their clothes and a few of their like
personal belongings like jewelry and
stuff all of their camping equipment
like they never found any of their
camping stuff they never found any of
their backpacks or any of the [ __ ] that
they had with him like bed rolls nothing
they never found any of that
it was you'll find out but yeah they
they would just find the bodies and the
clothes and maybe some jewelry but
that's it they've just all the stuff
that was with them they never
found it so they thought that was kind
of an interesting thing so at this point
like I said they weren't certain who it
was so they had somebody come in like a
profiler come in and like try to figure
out and you know he figured out the same
thing it's probably some loner and it's
semi-skilled or a low skilled occupation
you know probably working-class whatnot
you know who lived in the area was
probably a hunter and everything so at
this point the government of New South
Wales offered a five hundred thousand
dollar reward Australian dollars for
information leading to the conviction in
the first 24 hours they got over five
thousand phone calls so there were about
10,000 leads that they had to follow up
on far as I know none of these really
kind of led to anything so what they
started to do they had this computer
system and it was called net map and
they pretty much fed in all of the
information that they knew like he drew
for it four-wheel drive vehicle the type
of gun that he had blah blah blah all
this other stuff and so they wanted to
make like connections between these
things and see if like they got any
matches with somebody that had been
convicted before they used like
satellite photographs of the dump sites
and all this other kind of stuff and
they just kind of fed all of it into the
information now as I mentioned before
right around the time that all of this
was happening they also Paul onions in
England also been in contact with them
and told them about his narrow escape
back in 1990 and the one thing that a
lot of the that he had said was that the
guy had said his name was Bill which was
something that other people that had
seen him like aura had been picked up by
him and like just you know got out of
the car or whatever they said that was
another thing that he would tell
everybody that his name was bill even
though it wasn't his name so he you know
gets in touch with the cops they finally
you know try to start putting this [ __ ]
together with like the guy that he got
away from and all this other kind of
stuff so they finally start putting all
of this [ __ ] together
now there was another weird thing that
happened to that might have kind of kind
of contributed to Ivan Milat getting
caught why
you smirking I'm gonna change my name is
dude yes you're a guy hey guy I know
well you know yeah I'm I'm random random
satchel you gonna be white sauce white
sauce oh yeah oh Santa Blanca sounds oh
that's sexy
yeah well that's evidently in Mexico
Sancho is a stereotypical name for the
dude who runs off with your girlfriend
okay Jodi it does kind of man [ __ ] and
see you didn't even know that when I
said [ __ ] not channel that you channeled
it right out of the ether yeah because
you knew that it was after dimension
that was that was your name quality was
calling out to universal consciousness
yeah yeah yeah can you and can you get
Santa embroidered on it [ __ ] right yeah
damn rose carry a rose but they [ __ ] my
teeth [ __ ] play guitar
nice yeah I like it yeah that's gonna be
your new look alright okay so as I said
so there's getting together with Paulo
onions a guy who had escaped from this
guy and they also went back through
their files and found a very weird
a story from October of 1993 now it
turned out that Ivan Milat brother Alex
and I still don't know why he did this
Ivan's brother Alex contacted the police
in October of 1993 and he told them you
know 18 months ago I saw two women tied
up in the back of two cars and there was
like a group of men in these two cars
and it was near the bull Anglo state
forest now so they're speculating once
they get caught Ivan Milat they're like
okay now why did Alex call with this
story of these guys with the two women
tied up
it was either because one of the
vehicles he described was a vehicle that
Ivan had so they couldn't figure out
because they couldn't corroborate like a
lot of the details like with the dates
and [ __ ] and everything so it's like was
he just trying to like throw the police
off his brother's trail or off his own
trail cuz like maybe he was there too or
was he trying to turn his brother in but
he was too dumb to do it right or what
like it just seemed like a really weird
detail but the fact that he had called
about it and that that name kept coming
up you know the Millat family was enough
to kind of make them go more into it
they also came across the old report
that this woman who was married to
somebody that had worked at this
building materials plant and that she
said oh well this guy that my husband
works with I think that he's been out
there like killing people or maybe doing
this kind of stuff and maybe you should
look into him and this tip had been made
in early October so this worker that she
was talking about was actually named
Paul Miller but this was a pseudonym and
they actually found out that this was
Richard millat who was Ivan's younger
brother so like I said this whole family
is sketchy you know what I mean so and
in a way it's kind of good that they're
sketchy because it does seem like all
these little [ __ ] that they're brought
that the brother did like was kind of
like conspiring to make them sort of
close in on Ivan
so allegedly after Ivan was caught and
then there was like a murder trial
Richard millat the brother apparently
told people at work quote there's more
out there they haven't found them all
yet and also allegedly his workmates
said that before the bodies of the
German hitchhikers were found he had
said to them they haven't found the
Germans out there yet and I know who
killed the Germans he apparently said
this to people that he was someone that
he worked with and they came forward
later inside and this was before the
Germans the bodies of the Germans had
been found so he uh you know this guy
like I said he also said like weird [ __ ]
like stabbing a woman is like cutting a
loaf of bread which that's what I mean
why would you say something like that
so that's well and that's why a lot of
people think that maybe one of the
brothers particularly Richard might have
been there or might have known about
what was going on you know what I mean
there might have been at some or all of
the scenes just because he would say
like weird creepy [ __ ] like that maybe
he took maybe he took a brother there
every now and then that's what I'm
saying
like and and some like I said there's a
lot of controversy over whether there
was another person at the scene or not
because like I said some of the scenes
had different had two different weapons
and like different methods of killing
and [ __ ] like that and maybe it was
easier for two guys to wrangle two
people you know what I mean so there's a
possibility that there was to be like
some people like some of like forensic
scientists and stuff that I looked into
it said there was probably like more
than one killer and because of the
Millat family weirdness they're figuring
it's probably one of the brothers
because some of them have made
statements that made it seem like they
were probably there yeah or you know
might have been there or at least knew
about what was going on motive was
robbery or just thrills both it seems
like I mean he started it Ivan Milat
started out as a kid like as you know
just robbing people like breaking and
stealing [ __ ] but you know it just kept
getting warmer and I think when it got
to the end yeah you would steal [ __ ] but
I don't think that was
the motivation I think he just took the
[ __ ] because it was there by the
Australians yeah yeah he killed one
Australian couple yeah they were well
they weren't a couple they were friends
it was male and female friend pride
psychologically be easier for them to
kill foreigners I think that's what yeah
because I think the Australians were the
first ones that he killed and then I
think maybe he thought it would be
easier like people that weren't supposed
to be here
yeah yeah because like they they
wouldn't have family around maybe it
would be like harder for them to catch
him and show I think it might just be
more acceptable yeah because you're
killing invaders you're killing
foreigners yeah he might be looking at
it that way it wouldn't shot they're not
related to us yeah if we were so I know
the country right they're not supposed
to be here and there was kind of some
[ __ ] too because they think I believe it
was Richard millat the brother that said
about the loaf of bread thing I think
that he actually referred to it might
have been he might have been referring
to Paul Onion's the guy that got away as
calling him that pommy backpacker Tommy
being you know an Englishman that's like
kind of a derogatory term for an
Englishman so they did seem to have and
particularly like I said when I was
watching the interview with Richard
millat I mean they definitely do seem to
have like been a like gay people they
don't like English people they don't
like you know I mean they seem like one
of those kind of well what you could do
is you could you could you could sell
this to your brothers by saying well
it's gonna man we're gonna Rob some of
these foreigners that you know that I'm
in somebody's foreigners we're not gonna
take from our own people yeah we're
gonna take from these foreigners yeah
and then when you strive the foreigner
you kill the foreigners and then the
brothers are like maybe didn't know that
that was gonna happen and I what [ __ ]
was that about yeah [ __ ] them they're
just foreigners and like I said they I
mean even going back to when they were
kids
they really seemed to like always cover
each other's asses so even if one of
them even if even if they did know about
or if they were they were there they
wouldn't like ever narc on each other
they just wouldn't do it
and and like I said they still like
later on even nowadays the ones that are
still alive other than Boris he's the
only one that's kind of broken ranks
with the family but all of the other
ones are like they they think that Ivan
was set up by the cops like that the
cops produced like this voluminous
amount of
that they produced at the trial to show
that he was guilty
and they just think they they planted
all that and that somebody else did it
and he was like railroaded which I'm
sorry I just um I know some guys would
come up with we're not gonna steal from
our own people we're gonna steal from
foreigners yeah and you know his motive
is really more sexual and about
violence's yeah more than robbery but he
doesn't really
he doesn't really that's not the angle
he sold to his accomplices right with
you know I mean and maybe I don't I kind
of got a feeling that the brothers
weren't into it yeah they might not have
been saw that happen and they weren't
gonna rat him out but then maybe they
weren't do it again with him yeah maybe
they just like it might have been I mean
you know it's um why it would be strange
for them all to be murderous cigarettes
like that's not really my bad yeah just
tell me about it right so by the end of
1993 the cops start discretely asking
around about Ivan at his employer which
I think that was called the NSW Road and
traffic Authority now they found out
because they looked into Richard millat
because of all the creepy [ __ ] that he
said they looked into all his like
holiday time and [ __ ] like that now he
had apparently been working on the days
when the backpackers disappeared however
Ivan coincidentally had days off on
every single one of the days that the
backpackers went missing he was always
off of work that day yeah so mm-hmm so
all those dates matched up they also
went to his brother Walter to his house
and they said well we're checking like
gun licenses or whatever they wanted to
get to Ivan to see if he had the same
firearms that they had founded the thing
but Ivan apparently found out about
I guess maybe the brother like tipped
him off or whatever and he starts kind
of hiding his firearms in various places
Lou as we'll see he didn't really hide
them very well so as they're looking
more into Ivan's past they finally
figure they finally find his acquittal
for the rape and burglary from 1971 so
they think that's some more ammunition
so they decided it's like they didn't
have enough evidence to arrest him
obviously but he was like their prime
suspect at this point so they decided to
put him under surveillance you know
they've had little guys out in
tradesmen's vans or whatever and they
would just like sit in front of his
house now Ivan knew that he was under
surveillance because they would often
see him looking out the windows with
binoculars and [ __ ] like that but the
weird thing is that as I said he had a
lot of a really lot of evidence like in
his house and in his family's houses and
even though he knew he was under
surveillance he didn't get rid of it you
know I mean which i think is very weird
but maybe he wanted to get caught
I don't really know so um after uh let's
see okay so after Paul onions the
English guy who had escaped he actually
was secretly flown to Australia and they
showed him like all these pictures and
[ __ ] like that and he picked Ivan Milat
out of a lineup and so he also like
showed them where he had been taken and
there was like all this other kind of
stuff so he remembered the guy they also
talked to Ivan's ex-wife Karen who had
taken off and left him and she said even
though Ivan said that he had never been
into the Belenko forest she's like oh no
it's like we went there lots of times
it's like we went there for picnics and
you know he went there a few times on
his own like hunting and things like
that so so they found out he was lying
about that so then they go to interview
Alex Mille at about what was this story
about the guys in the car with the tied
up girls and it's like what was that all
about
and when they went to interview Alex his
wife
Joan hands the police a backpack and she
says Ivan gave us this because it
belonged to a friend of his and the
friend went back to New Zealand and they
didn't need it anymore so you guys can
have it this backpack belonged to Simone
Schmitt all one of the women who had
been murdered so apparently what Ivan
was doing he was taking all of their
[ __ ] like their backpacks cameras all
this kind of other kind of stuff and he
was either keeping it in his house or he
was giving it to his family members like
as gifts hmm like here here's his back
here's some clothes here's all this
other kind of stuff now one of the
things too that they found was that the
weird thing that was that one of the
guys cameras and like one of his
backpacks they found it like on the side
of a road like it had been put there
specifically like quite a lot it was
like a hundred kilometers away from
where his body was eventually found they
think that he might have put that there
like to throw cops off the scent like
you know so they wouldn't find the body
as quickly and [ __ ] but the rest of this
stuff other cameras clothes everything
like that
they found either in his house or in the
house of one of his siblings yeah this
thinking was is that he that he was so
tactical and so sneaky they would never
suspect him
yeah like that I think that's what it
was I think he was overconfident oh yeah
because obviously he was keeping all
this [ __ ] around he even had he had
given his girlfriend like he did divorce
from his wife but he later ended up I
think he married again like this this
half Indian woman she was like a she
worked at a college or something like
that she was a little bit older than him
but they actually ended up marrying
later and she was actually still with
him when he was arrested but he had
given her you remember Benetton yeah
like he had given her like a Benetton
top and that top belonged to Caroline
Clarke one of the English backpackers
like and there was a there was even a
picture of Caroline there was more than
one picture of Caroline like wearing
this top and they said significantly
this time
was actually the style was sold in
England but not in Australia so because
of course Ivan and all the family
members tried to say it's like oh well
this is our stuff it's like you know we
bought it here you know [ __ ] like that
so they tried to make it seem like but
the thing about it though was that when
they started searching all this because
once they found that [ __ ] they they took
out search warrants I'm like seven of
their properties because they kept
finding backpacks they kept finding all
this stuff you know not only found stuff
that presumably like even Paul Onion's
who had escaped his backpack had still
been in the car when he took off running
obviously so they even found [ __ ] that
belonged to him but they found a green
water bottle and it had been it had
something on the side that had been
scratched off but they did like
ultraviolet or whatever or infrared or
whatever like camera on it and it said
Simeon it which was Simone Schmidt all's
nickname she had like written it on
there and he had tried to scratch it out
so the fact that they're sitting there
so this is our stuff they're like yeah I
don't think so so yeah so finally they
they go to Ivan's house on May 22nd and
this was 1994 I told him to come out
with his hands up he had first ignored
it because he thought it they were
joking
so his girlfriend actually comes out
because finally they just kept yelling
and she came out and she said there was
fifty armed police surrounding the house
so he gets arrested now they yes so they
interrogated him at first for three
hours asked him various questions about
the the car that he drove the four-wheel
drive they asked him if he owned a Ruger
10/22 rifle he said no they asked if
he'd ever used the name bill he said no
so they actually didn't have they only
had circumstantial evidence they said
okay well what we're gonna do because
Paul onions is still alive and he had
flown to Australia to help in the
investigation said they wanted to charge
him armed robbery and kidnapping in his
case and you know so they would have
something to hold him on until they got
more evidence you know so they were able
to do
and then 31st of May they actually
thought they had enough stuff to charge
him and at that point they formally
charged him with seven murders of the
seven backpackers and the attempted
abduction of Paul onions as well as
various firearms offenses because there
were he had a lot of guns and that was
legal then but there was some that he
wasn't allowed to have what happened
with his head on the stick angle well
like I said that was something I don't
think he ever said that in particular
but that was something that they made up
for the movie but that was something
that he would do to most of his victims
he apparently knew he had like this big
hunting knife and he apparently knew the
spot where you could like insert it
because either most or all of the
victims had their spine severed at a
particular place that if you just
plunged it in there and then cut upwards
which is what he would do then that
person would just be paralyzed they
would still be conscious but they would
be paralyzed and how many a.m. did he do
this do at least three of them it might
have been more but I know it was at
least three of them - the male's the
females both and still and while he was
raping them or while he was doing other
things that he wanted them to watch I
guess but like I said since that was
such a horrific detail that was one
thing that I remembered from the movie
Wolf Creek because that was something
that the killer I think his name was
Mick in that one but he would do that
too but he called it head on a stick
because it was mostly that mostly he
killed them by stabbing or shooting
stabbing or shooting or strangling some
of them he strangled and shot and
stabbed with their torture involved um
I'm not really sure because it did seem
like so many more executions it seemed
like more execution and it seemed like
overkill but a lot of the [ __ ] might
have been done after they were dead like
I said he would you know he would do the
thing and like paralyze them but then
you know it but then he would just shoot
them in the head but then he'd keep
shooting them in the head or he would
stab them and they'd be dead and keep
stabbing them or you know the one girl
he beheaded with a sword but they think
she was still alive so that was like an
execution also where so it just seemed
like I don't know it just seems really
weird because yes some of them were
raped but it doesn't
like it doesn't seem like he wanted to
do sexual mutilations or a sexual kind
of it it's almost kind of like he just
liked to make people suffer or he just
liked to kill people like no other
reason than that he just seemed to enjoy
it
right trying to put him on par with
somebody yeah it's it's hard to think of
someone that was kind of kind of like
that like that seems pretty kind of
unique actually yeah that's what I
thought because he doesn't have like a
cut-and-dried yeah
motive really a real common one would be
you know along the lines of you know BTK
actually well now BTK wasn't that common
trying to say yeah and BTK that seemed
very sexual right this guy like I said I
he did rape some of the girls but it's
like I don't know if that was the
primary motivation yeah you know what I
mean it just seemed like he just did it
because he was there just like just cuz
they were there just like he would steal
their stuff cuz it was there I don't
think that was really I don't really
even think he thought that much about it
it was just something he liked to do all
these serial killers are kind of unique
in their own way yeah but I mean there
are types but yeah would you say it'd be
like a real common type my gosh yeah no
that's like you kind of put me on the
spot I know like there are common types
cuz a lot of them are very similar but
but the mo sir yeah and the motives are
kind of different I would probably say
because when you can put faces to you to
the crimes and you know that offender
they do come off as being pretty
different yeah well you know everyone's
individuals I guess even serial killers
which is [ __ ] up but like I said there
are patterns obviously but everyone's
different right so this guy I'm sure
there's another one out there that's
kind of like
we can't this guy seems more like I mean
if you're gonna um I mean this is not
like Bundy yeah this was just thing - it
would be like Bundy but not really this
guy seems more like sexual yeah this guy
seems more like one of those you know
like maybe one of those like trucker
serial killers that they haven't caught
yet there's just like they'll pick up a
prostitute and have sex with them and
then they don't torture them or nothing
like that they just then they just shoot
them and dump them somewhere yeah it
just seems like no sexual it is yeah I
guess this almost seems like like it's
more kinda like robbery and murder yeah
not even so much sexual yeah to me it
just seemed like he just liked killing
people I don't see sex as the primary
mode it doesn't seem to be that's what
I'm saying I don't really see robbery as
the primary motive didn't really have
anything of value yeah they just had
like clothes and cameras like tourist
[ __ ] they would just had tourists what
kind of like he's doing something
hunting humans yes it definitely like
struck me more as that where he just was
doing it because he could almost kind of
like something like Jason from Friday
the 13th yeah it is like that it's just
go hot some teenage girls yeah and then
he's just they he doesn't like I said he
doesn't really do it he just like kind
of executes them yeah I mean they were
it was very violent like the crimes were
very violent and I can't think of any
other one that was like that I can't
either really I mean I'm sure there is
and it's just not coming to me but yeah
this it is it's a very unusual case
killer primarily is a rapist yeah a
rapist and he kills the victim this guy
doesn't come across to me as as a serial
rape okay you know although he did start
out as a rapist you know that you know
what this almost kind it's almost kind
of like this zodiac but he's not talking
the zodiac kind of did that but he's
yeah not a Sam Lovers Lane [ __ ] so you
could say that was kind of sexual too in
a way although he didn't do anything I
mean the thing about zodiac was that
everything was just distant he would
just come up and shoot you and leave
it's like he didn't really he didn't
really hang out at the scene he didn't
like torture the anybody
yeah that's what I mean it's just scary
do you think there's kind of yeah well
like I said you can see why they made a
[ __ ] movie about this dude
I mean loosely it's based on another guy
tale but so while this jackal is in
custody they search his house and while
they're questioning him he of course
denies every single [ __ ] thing I have
no idea was talking about I did not do
this I did not do that however while the
cops were searching the house they found
cartridges for 22
they found electrical tape which was
very similar to that used at the murder
scenes in a spare room of his house they
also found a manual for a Ruger 10/22
more ammunition for it the same weapon
they also found a bowie knife which they
think was very similar to what had been
used in the stabbings
they also found a thirty-two browning
pistol which I think was and the
ammunition for that which I think was
also they had found some casings for
that at some of the scenes also then
inside a wall cavity they found a
disassembled parts of a Ruger 10/22 like
stuffed hidden in a wall hmm part of the
trigger assembly and they did ballistics
tests on this and determined that it was
the same one that had been used in the
murders
they also found other parts of the same
gun and a cupboard in the house they
also found a map of the Blanco State
Forest so this is looking a little
incriminating what's funny is that he
thinks he can because if they find the
weapon he doesn't think he could be
caught they find all that clothing right
what the [ __ ] did he think because this
is what is it was a lot of stuff it was
a lot of clothes and [ __ ] like that
a lot of [ __ ] well yeah didn't know
anything about investigative technique I
think a lot of these guys like I said
overconfident well the thing about a lot
and this might be true of like not just
serial killers but people in general
it's like there are people that are
above average intelligence but that's
more but they're not that smart but they
think they're smarter than everyone else
because people that are really smart if
you're really smart you know you're
stupid and you don't know anything so
you're like super careful about you know
what I mean because you know that
there's a lot of [ __ ] that you don't
know
our people do not underestimate exactly
but when you're just like slight like
when you're above average intelligence
but not like genius or anything like
that then I think you tend to think
everyone is dumber than you and you get
super cocky where the danger comes in
though is that there are people of only
above-average intelligence that work
their way into corporate and government
positions of power well yeah that are
smart enough to outsmart other people in
government and corporate power and they
[ __ ] kind of Masel a lot of wealth
but they underestimate the intelligence
of Avila and they they have a hard time
predicting people's reactions look at
[ __ ] today corporations are how out of
touch they are with a lot of people you
know you can just look see what's going
on in modern culture you know rich and
powerful people really for a lot of
times don't know what's going on well
yeah and like I said I think it can't
predict a reaction to the [ __ ] that they
do like that come out like [ __ ] that
Google comes out with a crazy policy and
there's a lot of blowback and they were
like well why did that happen well
[ __ ] you not I mean you don't you
don't have contact with the average
person oh yeah and like I said I don't
think it's wise to ever like
underestimate but I think that's very
common with particularly Siri cuz some
serial killers are just like stupid
lowlifes
you know arming them out of them were
our because well yeah and I feel like
there's like a misperception that serial
killers like these big and maybe because
a Hannibal Lecter and [ __ ] like that and
you get every now and then there's one
that is intelligent and stuff but most
of them I think are just like average or
lower average intelligence but when you
get one that's like a little bit smarter
than the average person like we're
talking about like like Dennis here like
Dennis yeah Dennis could have got away
with it yeah he shut his [ __ ] mouth
that's what I mean okay idiot yeah
because he was just mad because yeah
like I said he'd got away with it for
what 20 30 years no one had caught him
he wasn't on anyone's radar no he just
couldn't stand it he couldn't stand it
and he just had to start like and and
that was the whole dumb thing about is
like hey can you catch me from a floppy
just like nah bro
fine yeah very trusting why did the
tomato come I wonder why that could be a
cop sir honorable you really are an
idiot but yeah so I mean I'm glad he's
an idiot because he wouldn't got caught
otherwise but I think I think probably
he represents the upper upper end of the
spectrum upper tier of like intelligence
yeah he really got away with it
yeah but either he wanted to get caught
or or he was just so or he just couldn't
control himself yeah you know I mean he
had to he was so much into himself that
he had to continue I think it was about
himself because it is been so long that
I don't think he would have even been
worried about getting caught any more so
I don't even think that he wanted to get
caught particularly I think that he just
couldn't stand it because people weren't
talking about him anymore that's what I
think it was I think it was just it like
a ego yeah and he probably thought like
he said he probably thought he could get
away with it he's like I'm just gonna
start talking to him again so I'll be in
the news and then when when they get
ahold of Dennis she find out that Dennis
is intelligent but he's not that
intelligent that's what I'm saying it's
like a lot of times it's just kind of
like it's not your genius people it's
your people that are like a level or two
below that and they and they think that
they're smarter than everyone else even
they're not like I said a really smart
person knows that they don't know
everything you know what I mean people
are not serial killers
exactly oh yeah because if you're super
smart it's like yeah I'm not gonna get
it so yeah so like not like I said not
only do they find the parts of this gun
like hidden in his wall and in the cabin
and everything like that as I said they
found a camera which belonged to
Caroline Clark they found the water
bottle that belonged to sh munch some
bunch metal that had her name on it but
had been scratched off they found a
bunch of foreign coins from the UK and
also from Germany which they think had
belonged to the people in the garage
they found a pillowcase that had five
sash cords one of the sash cords had D
had blood on it and the DNA showed that
it belonged to Caroline Clark so as I
said they found all this [ __ ] in
his house and in his like you know
siblings houses because he had given
them stuff like I said hey here's some
free clothes here's a camera here's the
Sun the other thing they're just not
that smart yeah that's what I'm saying
and like I said they even found a
picture of Ivan's girlfriend wearing
Caroline's top I mean all you gotta do
is just apply the same rules as say like
contamination yeah amical contamination
you don't want to be connected with
anything that has a connection to the
crime scene now yeah just the crime
scene things that connect you to the
crime scene can't be there so taking
things from the crime scene and bringing
that into your own house the fatal flaw
yeah and then leaving it I would you
think that because that's putting you at
the scene that's right
it's like if they can't put you at the
scene you still have plausible
deniability the offender deposits
evidence at the scene and he takes
evidence away you try to minimize that
yeah you don't want to get caught that
is criminal 101 minimize the amount of
evidence you take to the crime scene and
you minimize to any of the evidence that
you take from the crime scene
yeah you don't take a whole backpack of
[ __ ] and take it back we there should be
no crime scene well yeah that's if
there's no cross from a criminals point
of view that's like the perfect is
perfect crimes yes no crime scene
there's no complaint of a crime yeah
there's no there's you know I mean
that's yeah nobody knows no body there's
no investigation and without that
investigation there can never be an
indictment yeah you know so like I said
I don't I don't get it but yeah so as I
said not only they find all this [ __ ] in
his house in his brother Walters house
they also found and and shuts is that
how you say it and shit's 22 rifle on
shoes this so they found one of those
which had actually been used at one of
the murder scenes because like I said
there were two different guns used which
is why they think maybe there was it is
yeah yeah and they also found a backpack
at Walters house which belonged to
Simone Schmitt all at rich
melot's property they found a tent
belonging to Caroline Clarke and also a
bedroll belonging to her at Alex's house
they found Simone's backpack as I said
his wife gave it to them and at Margaret
melot's house that was their mother they
actually found a t-shirt belonging to
Simone and a t-shirt that belonged to
Paul onions the guy that got away so
there's like stuff just distribute it
all throughout the family about that
when Ivan Milat was in prison for some
other charge back in the 1970s he had
told this other prisoner named Noel
Manning that he had raped a girl and
stabbed her in the spine to paralyze her
before it happened
right so that was a tip-off right there
because that was very similar to what he
had done you know to some of the other
ones so Ivan Milat trial began in March
of 1996 I believe now his defense was he
was trying to stir up doubt that either
some of his brothers had committed the
crimes and planted the evidence on him
or that it was all railroaded by the
cops like they had all planted evidence
right now it's like he did actually take
the stand in his own defense and [ __ ]
like that but it's it seems like he lost
a lot of jury sympathy when the defense
attorney pretty much came out and said
so you are telling me that you think
someone broke into your house even
though you have all these alarm systems
and [ __ ] like that took this particular
gun that was like put it and put it
behind the wall and like you didn't know
and also the stuff and he it's like this
big long thing like what must have
happened and he said and I quote well
they must have and everyone was like
[Music]
that's how it happened so uh yeah so
over the course of the trial like and
like I said that was just kind of like
he tried to come up with all these
[ __ ] things but it's like you know
it's how all was he more or less by this
um 3040 I think he was late 30s early
40s maybe yes so so no one bought it he
got guilty of all seven murders and it
was actually like some job
she's like no I've caused trouble and
now I'm leaving
but yeah so yes so he was convicted of
all that all seven murders and also the
attempted kidnapping of Paul onions and
was sentenced to life in prison after he
was convicted they started looking into
some other unsolved murders that he
might have committed as well although he
was never convicted of them particularly
there was one of an eighteen-year-old
kid named Peter Letcher and he was
actually found in a gentleman gentleman
state Forrest I guess that's how you
pronounce it in January of 1988 and the
method of murder was very similar to
what Ivan Milat did so they think maybe
he might have done more than he was
convicted for but as I said they never
bothered to get a conviction because he
was already in prison so they take him
to jail and apparently he gets
transported to the maximum-security
prison in Maitland which is southwest of
Sydney he was he gets into the prison
and he's walking in there like to the
showers or whatever and this other big
prisoner just comes in just like punches
him right in the face so it's like you
know welcome to prison [ __ ] so another
thing that he tried to do a lot in
prison was he was always trying to
escape like he always had like some
[ __ ] escape plans right because he
protested his innocence the whole entire
time and as I said pretty much everyone
in his family his mother up until she
died almost all of his brothers except
for Boris said that they thought that he
was railroaded that they didn't think
that he had done it although Boris I
like Boris because he's on like a lot of
um you know documentaries about Ivan
Milat and he'll basically come out and
say you know I think he's a psychopath
and I don't have a problem believing
that he did it and he's like the whole
family hates me because I say that but
he says that at least two or three of
the brothers have said to him privately
that they think Ivan is guilty but they
won't come out publicly and say it I
don't know if that's true that's just
what he says but he has no compunctions
about coming out and saying that
although like that's what I'm saying I
kind of suspect particularly Richard
MLAT and he was interviewed in some of
these - just some of the
he said because like I think later on
they um they had a friend of his like
wear a wire and he said like he didn't
come out and admit anything but some of
the [ __ ] he said implied that he could
have been there you know what I'm saying
like he knew about some particular
injuries of like one of the people that
hadn't really been released and stuff so
they do think that maybe he at least
knew about and knew it was going on or
he was like actually there but he's
never been convicted of anything so the
salt allegedly and [ __ ] like that also a
lot of the family thought that they were
still under surveillance for a long time
after you know after Ivan went to prison
and everything now yes so Boris actually
when they asked him how many people do
you think that Ivan killed he thinks
that it's more like 28 people so I think
there's like the family knew some [ __ ]
that was going on even if they weren't
there I think they probably knew now
another thing that Ivan did aside from
trying to like [ __ ] escape all the
time like they fought one time they
found like a hacksaw blade like inside
of a cookie packet you know [ __ ] like
that and then he did he would do like
self-harm [ __ ] like he would like
swallow razor blades and like needles
and all this other kind of stuff you go
on a hunger strike and he lost like 50
pounds he did all this kind of crap in
January of 2009 he actually cut off his
little finger with a plastic knife he
was gonna mail it to the High Court
because he wanted an appeal like oh he
cut his little finger off with a plastic
knife he had some willpower didn't yeah
I guess so but yeah like I said he would
all he also did like you know swallowing
staples and razor blades and [ __ ] like
that the hunger strikes that he did that
was in 2011 it was nine days he lost 55
pounds I was like in nine days holy [ __ ]
that's pretty good but he did that
because he wanted a Playstation and they
wouldn't give him one so you know yes so
as I said at the beginning of the show I
especially wanted to move this guy up in
the ranks because this guy just died in
May 2000 19
ivan was actually transferred to Prince
of Wales hospital and he had they
diagnosed him with esophageal cancer so
good good news so they knew that there
was nothing they could do about it by
the time that they caught it so in
August early August they moved him to us
to a treatment unit at the Prince of
Wales Hospital he lost another 44 pounds
subsequently and had a high temperature
and then he died at 4:07 a.m. on October
27th 2019 which was only a couple of
days ago I was recording this he was 74
years old okay so he was older than we
thought he was yes so good riddance like
I 74 he actually live kind of a full
life yeah although you know I don't know
it's a I I kind of hope this is terrible
to say well I guess it's not but I was
gonna say I hope that [ __ ] cancer
hurt that's all yeah that's a shame
but yeah all the [ __ ] that all those
people have poor people had to go
through and like I said his family
almost all of his families still think
that he didn't do anything or they still
publicly say this is pretty unique yeah
that's what I thought
he's more like just a psychopathic
bandit yeah he asked me he's almost kind
of like those old like dudes back in the
Old West yeah like where they would just
like my way man yeah he's like that and
he just raped some of the women but
those old Heidi women did that back then
too yeah just like I said cuz it was
there yeah and why not man it was just
like [ __ ] yeah this is exactly what this
guy he's like evil Crocodile Dundee like
yeah you got it comes across like that a
little bit sorry crocodile yeah I know
you're a fictional character in
teresting Lee and I just found this
while I was researching this in 2012
Ivan Milat s' great-nephew Matthew
millat was also convicted of murder him
and a friend of his axed a third friend
of theirs to death rest in the same
forest where Ivan took all the
backpackers yeah isn't that special so
yeah he got life as well
it's [ __ ] family it's kind of rare to
have like a bunch of hardcore crime
happening in rural areas yeah I mean it
does happen but well the people are
farther apart too so it's like that you
don't have the most really show each
other yeah so if somebody gets up to
some shenanigans the stress it'll get
around dress levels are also lower trail
under a lot of environmental pressure I
guess they're not yeah yeah easy lives
drinking getting high playing video
games they're not under big pressures in
terms of you know you know job
performance and stuff and yeah that
strain collect Social Security they have
to yeah but yeah so at this [ __ ]
Matthew millat who like I said is the
great nephew of Ivan Milat at his trial
he was only 17 or 18 at the time and he
said on the stand they said that he
gloated about the murder like I said
this was like a third friend and they
was like a double-bladed axe and they
just like [ __ ] chopped him up because
I think he he thought that the friend
was like talking [ __ ] about him or
something so he said well I'm just gonna
take him into the woods and like how
does that offer whatever yeah cuz cuz
that's a totally reasonable thing to do
so yeah so he's up there on the stand
like kind of like happy about it and he
said and I quote you know me you know my
family you know the last name a lot I
did what they do
so what's weird about this is that you
know it doesn't have the motives that's
what I thought was interesting about
this to you it's like I just I've read
like so much about this dude and I'm
just saying they're going like what I
mean you can look at what's happening in
Mexico with these cartel Wars going on
you know there if I can cut in people's
face off boiling people alive but at
least there's some motive there's a
they're there they're fighting over the
drug wars their drugs yeah it's like
it's horrible but there's a reason to
read the other fighting over the drug
trade or the local police have collapsed
and really the cartels are now the local
police and they're bringing vigilante
justice on another damn yeah
organized crime syndicate
did some well yeah they're trying to
like intimidate their enemies and [ __ ]
like that so it's even though you know
you can just google for the photos of
the crime cartel victims you know all
the beheadings you look at you go man
that's gross that's grotesque [ __ ] but
really that's what you saw for thousands
of years with tribal warfare it's
exactly exact same thing cutting
people's hearts out cutting people yeah
that's the same imitation it's gang
versus gang or tribe versus tribe so
it's in a way more understandable this
their the motive isn't really they're
just you know that's what I'm sayin I
don't get this guy I don't get a sense
this guy is almost kind of like like I
read about a lot of criminals and serial
killers and stuff like that and like I
said I don't sympathize with them or
anything like that but a lot of times
like I can I can see oh I can see how
that might have gone wrong or I can see
how that might have happened
this guy just seems like a blank yeah
like a blank nothing well he might have
been you know he didn't achieve what he
wanted to achieve and life and was bored
a lot living out in the middle of
nowhere really wasn't going anywhere in
his life he was a hunter so you decided
to hunt some innocent people yeah it
definitely doesn't seem like there's any
deeper thrill motive about it like he
just it was just something to do he was
already kind of a psychopath or
sociopath and he just evolved into doing
that yeah that's kind of the thing that
I got I didn't think he thought it was
that big of a deal more like no he
didn't seem to like it was just kind of
like a side gig I don't even know if
anyone in the family really thought it
was that big a deal because like I said
I know for sure I don't know if any of
the other ones were like involved like
at the crime scene but I'm for sure at
least some of them knew about well they
were foreigners that's where their
thinking was as well they're foreigners
he's not killing people that we know
around here yeah that's so whatever yeah
they're like and we're getting free [ __ ]
out of it so I guess they didn't like
tournament or nothing like that
well they you know just psychotic you
know psychology will tell you that you
know historically it's easier to kill
people from other countries because yeah
because they're not like you're outside
your yeah group or they're outside your
you know your your local group so it's a
it's
it's an ounce you know they're Outsiders
yeah so that yeah that might have been
these days their eventual people you
know yeah Big Joe well like I said I saw
more than one you know copper
investigator call them Hillbillies it's
not yes some of you were supporting it
but they were more tolerant of it yeah
you know I mean like they weren't for it
but they weren't all that against it
right that's what I'm saying
it's like I that's why I think that I
don't know if his mom knew I don't know
if his sister his sister probably knew
because they were super close and they
lived together and for sure some of the
brothers if they weren't there at least
I think they knew what was going on but
like you said I don't think I don't
think they would go out and do it on
their own but I don't think they really
cared all that much like I do is just
look at old feudal Japan yeah if a
foreign ship every kind of you know
became shipwrecked on their Island you
don't be they boiled those dudes alive
because because they were Outsiders like
hers you're not from around here yeah
you don't belong here so you know they
just killed them yeah and it's just I
think you know traditionally it's kind
of like the first kind of response to
seeing an outsider if you're from an
enclosed area yeah and it may be
genetics has a lot to do with it - I
don't know it's like a xenophobia yeah
it's not as prevalent as it used to be
you know the main globalization has a
lot to do with it but then there's also
backlashes against everything yeah you
know humans are tribal did you start
yeah you can mitigate it and some people
are less that way and some people yeah I
mean the more you know about it the
easier it is to kind of like well there
are some people that know everything
about it and there's still hostile -
hell yeah you know what I mean there's
there was a what was it no it was
thinking of somewhere in Brazil some
Christian guy went up - it was an island
somewhere near the Amazon you'd say what
the butter Islands doing in the Amazon
somebody an audience member might know I
just saw a quick blurb on it people told
that dude don't go down there those
Indians will [ __ ] kill you they've
been kill
for hundreds of years he shows up with a
you know he shows up on their Shores
Bible in hand and everything in like
seven or eight am ran out there with
with bows and just shot him full arrows
and killed him they and they have always
attacked anyone from the outside yeah
there they don't have any modern you
know well they just feel like if you
show up there you show obviously me then
you're bad harm yeah you're bad cuz like
I said it's not good but you can
understand why maybe they have bad
experience yeah everybody that shows up
but like causes trouble well the theory
is is that a couple centuries back some
people showed up there were outsiders
and heard them right so that may haven't
forgotten it and they've been passing
down word-of-mouth that if you see any
these people showing up kill them
yeah and they do it without question but
yeah I just said that just happened like
a couple years back yeah there are still
some places in the world where you know
they do that I believe so yeah well like
are we gonna have like a global world I
don't think so I just think there's just
too much this disagreement between the
way things are done I mean who's gonna
run it yeah you know well you know is
this long I'm gonna run it no
everybody's gonna fight over who's gonna
run it you know no thinking they can't
even control who runs a United means
certain areas like the Middle East and
even South America they don't agree with
who's who runs South America it's like
human nature do you want more [ __ ] to
run it like I said it's it's something
that's never going to that's why there's
like no such thing as like utopia so
like things get better but you're gonna
get better but they're never all gonna
be but it's never all gonna be good or
perfect or anything like that because
people are just too different and have
different ideas about how you know it
will never be uniform right you'll get
better but they'll work it out but it'll
never be uniform you're gonna have
different cultures that's just that's
just gonna happen yeah but like I said
this it's supposed to be that way it
should be that way yeah you don't want
everybody to be the same
well no no one no one there would be no
diversity yeah you know culture yeah
I saw that they tried to sell that to us
in the 50s with the damn unit culture
corporate unit culture you know that
they trying to sell to white suburbia
yeah it's not maintainable you don't
want that you want a little bit of
differences
and I don't even think it worked in
practice you know yeah that was like the
idealized and everyone's like yeah I
think some people bought into it but I
don't think I'm on the ground I don't
really think it's for certain areas yeah
and it was only for a decade or so yeah
all right so I think we've probably gone
on and on long enough about Ivan Milat
on the backpacker murders I know this
was kind of like a little bit rambling
all over the place but like what else is
new so anyway I hope you enjoyed it
despite all of that and remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe on
all your social media share with all
your friends and family it really does
help us a lot to get new listeners and
stuff like that if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there is a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation some of
our fans do that as well and that is all
much appreciated
so I guess that'll do it for episode 168
we will see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]